let's make way for Bob Costas Hall of
Fame broadcaster Major League Baseball
Network host announcer and spent 40
years at NBC Bob joins us good morning
Bob how are you hey Dan how you doing
I'm doing okay I was talking about my
days as a Little League um did you ever
umpire I am hired a softball game once
and I was wearing a baseball cap and it
was sometime in the 80s so perhaps I
wasn't as well-known as I wound up being
at one point and the pitcher did not at
first recognized me and he was
vociferously disputing my calls and you
know softball slowpitch softball is
tough to umpire because of the arc of
the pitch coming in and he was calling
me everything in the book and then as
the half inning ended he walked off and
he was giving me another piece of his
mind and he got closer he goes yeah
that's right you believe your writer is
just a bleeping game well it's just a
game but baseball is making it a little
more interesting and the proposed
changes by the Commissioner yeah where
do you stand on this well let me preface
this by saying that no matter what I do
no matter how nuanced the point I make
there are some people who just want to
say what check with cosmesis heads going
to explode he's a purist my objection to
the first wildcard way back when was not
that it changed baseball but that it
changed it without foresight I said it
at the time forgive this little history
lesson you're going to have situations
where what used to be the most dramatic
games have no meaning at all and that
played out constantly we're at the end
of seasons teams that would have been
buying for the most important thing head
to head didn't care at all because one
or the other was already assured of a
wild card they'd rather get their
pitching in place and there was
virtually no difference between being a
wild card and being the team with the
best record in the league even if the
wild card came from the same division as
the team with the best record in the
league well if you can get to the ALCS
forget about we start all over again
that disrespected the meaning of the
full season and it took some of the
drama away and that wasn't just an
abstract thought it played out
after time when they went to the second
wild-card I approved of it because it
addressed at least some of those
concerns okay now we have this proposal
from the commissioner and we're not
going to run down all the complicated
whys and wherefores of it but I think
it's very interesting and it has a lot
of Merit I like it I'm ok with it I
don't think it messes with the integrity
of the game I like now there's two
things here if we add a couple more wild
card birth so if we give a first round
by okay then there's incentive for you
know I'd like that and then the other
part is the reality TV part of it which
I'm ok with if you want to have a
manager they're saying and we want to
play the angels and you know then all of
a sudden you've got this drama all they
wanted you guys and then you know so you
at least get something that's a little
more interesting there where do you
stand on the reality TV part of this
yeah I don't mind that at all in fact I
think it will be very interesting not
just as a selling point with the reality
TV part but from the standpoint of
strategy will you get some storyline and
it's not a bad thing where somebody in a
small market or the team that was the
seventh qualifier says oh well yeah well
they dissed us yeah you'll get some of
that and will there be you know the
Yankees or the Red Sox one of the other
gets to pick should they pick their
archrival or should they try to avoid
them and maybe meet them further down
the line that's all fine but there's
also strategy involved what if a team
you could potentially meet has already
got its pitching in order but the other
team had to go to the wire and throw
everything but the kitchen sink out
there in order to qualify maybe you
prefer that team in a best-of-three
rather than the other team you might not
prefer them if the slate was clean but
under these circumstances or maybe I
don't know that their best pitcher just
went on the injured list or you had a
particularly bad time with that team
that year they are more left handed in
their rotation and you're more left
handed in your lineup there's a lot of
interesting considerations there
and it doesn't have to be automatically
highest seed gets the lowest seed
talking to Bob costis Hall of Famer and
Major League Baseball Network host and
announcer is there anything else that
could come out with the Astros where you
would say you know what
when second thought let's take away the
title well I guess you it would have to
be confined to the 2017 season since I
got to the World Series last year when
there's some allegations about buzzers
but they didn't win it
I guess if something else came out but I
believe that right now the Commissioner
has closed the book on the 2017 season
and he's gonna leave it the way a lot of
things are left if you want to believe
that Barry Bonds 762 is the real record
go ahead if you want to believe that
Hank Aaron and Roger Maris are the real
career and single-season record holders
knowing what you know now
go ahead there's an asterisk in the
minds of fans who pay attention anyway
at least many of them and I think that's
the way baseball wants to leave it what
I think a lot of people have questions
about is what might have gone on
subsequently something a little more
sophisticated than banging on a trash
can and knowing that the Astros were
willing to engage in what Tom Verducci
has called these dark arts knowing that
they were willing to do it I'm not a
conspiracy theorist but you can't
discount the possibility that they did
it in different ways in different
seasons if I'm a Red Sox fan sell me on
us losing Mookie Betts it's the best we
could do under the circumstances if we
had been able to retain Mookie if we
thought that even a competitive bid
would keep him than we do so but we're
gonna lose him no matter what it's
difficult to rid ourselves of most they
had to pick up some of it but of most of
David prices contract so we were able to
package price with him in combination
this is going to give us some good young
players Alex Verdugo is definitely a
good young player and it's going to get
us into a position where and we've shown
that we've been able to do this as an
organization before that we'll be able
to read
and be competitive once again we wish we
could have kept mookie betts but there
was no way we were going to keep him
beyond this year and last year we bogged
down even with him on our team and
although we're not going to say this
publicly we know we're not going to be
as good as the Yankees this year with or
without mookie betts so we made the best
of a very bad situation yeah they might
not even have been better than Tampa
this year as well
the Dodgers it's a crowded outfield I I
mean they needed Gerrit Cole but the
pitching question mark here that's it
felt like that's what they need no I'm
not you're not sold on the bullpen so
the Dodgers go into this season and
granted they can always pick up somebody
but you got questions about the Dodgers
yeah how many games over a hundred
really win it's good to be in a
situation where you're looking for
weaknesses and I grant you that Kenley
Jansen has not been what he once was and
that is a consideration they do however
have a lot of pitching depth of course
any team would have loved to have
acquired Gerrit Cole Mookie Betts is not
a bad consolation prize their lineup is
hellacious yeah that's it I was thinking
about that you know the angels line of
it is pretty impressive as well Bob if
you know everybody's well they had jock
Peterson so they lost joc pederson but
still you know Otani in there and you
add Rendon and then you got a Mike Trout
in there best lineup in baseball Dodgers
Yankees other I'd go with the Dodgers
right now maybe I'm overlooking
something the Yankees obviously and a
homer happy era and in that ballpark the
Yankees will score a whole lot of runs
so I don't think they have any concerns
in that respect either it's interesting
you mentioned the Angels though adding
Joe Maddon should help them adding
Anthony grant own should help them a lot
they may not be done dealing if they
wanted joc pederson and they may look
elsewhere for another bat but with the
Astros weekend not just by the departure
of Cole and even with the arrival of
Dusty Baker which is obviously a plus
there's a little bit of dysfunction
going on there the A's are still a very
good team and in that division but my
point is that the Angels might be in a
position to make some kind of move this
year in the American League West if
everything breaks well for them
were you ever offered a job other than
broadcasting by team no no no front
office no manager no no I was offered a
dh5 by a struggling ball club but I just
I thought I was past my peak were you
ever interested in doing something like
that running at home no I was interested
in imaginations of it how it got done I
was always a student of it I was an
early proponent of Bill James when Bill
James was putting out his baseball
abstract literally mimeo grabbing it
from his home in Kansas I was receiving
it I was on a subscription list this is
in the early 80s and I would put him on
the radio on KMOX in st. Louis so all of
that sort of stuff how do you put a team
together what are the dynamics of a farm
system all that stuff interested me but
as someone who loves baseball and covers
baseball not as someone who thought he
should be part of the decision-making
I'll leave you with this I I have a
choice for the Knicks if they wanted to
add a front office person to run the
team yeah Theo Epstein if he'd leave the
Cubs yes if he ran if he did that for
the Red Sox did that for the Cubs I mean
if you can do it for the Cubs you can do
it for the Knicks right well what about
this then he's technically not free
Jeff Lew now is no I don't know if we
want to go down that road
I think Knicks fans are desperate enough
your premise if your premise is to be
accepted we're accepting your premise
for the purpose of this conversation
then they are desperate enough to try
almost anything
the Knicks should be allowed to cheat
Bob yeah right they should be allowed to
cheat three you should count for four
it's great to talk to you hope you're
doing well and appreciate your time as
always all right that's Bob Costas Hall
of Famer for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on Direct
a stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]